Clearly,
a religion has both positive and
negative.
The wars of religion clearly negative,
uh,
the idea that you have to have something
to believe,
some things to think about,
a important,
obviously technological advances.
Uh,
I read a recent statistic which just
blew my mind away that,
um,
today the average American has 10 times
as much material resources as the
American at the Americans had it,
the civil war,
um,
which is just a phenomenal thing when
you consider,
and it's all because of technological,
scientific and Tuck,
the logical advances and the ability to
harness energy,
the ability to transform energy,
just phenomenal driver in society.
And again,
both positive and,
you know,
we have better killing machines to,
uh,
and uh,
so,
uh,
both of those things are,
I think phenomenally important.
And you know,
we didn't have much progress,
uh,
in terms of improvement in living
standards for a millennia until really
the development,
uh,
in the 16th,
17th century of science and the ability
to transform science into technology.
And,
uh,
sometimes I think we don't appreciate
the flush toilet enough.
It's just indoor plumbing,
indoor heating.
I,
uh,
in the late 19 seventies and early
eighties lived in Oxford in rooms that
had no central heating.
You had a heating coil and,
uh,
I think you get to appreciate central
heating and the fact that you can
actually live at 70 degrees all year
round a lot more when you are freezing
and you can't actually get to sleep
because you're shivering so much.
Um,
and I think that's just a phenomenal
thing we take for granted in our
society.
And it's been a very short time since
that's been.